تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع
فيديو لم تتجاوز مدته نصف الدقيقه لعصفور
يجلس على راس معتمر اثناء الطواف حول
الكعبه وصفه البعض بالجميل والعفوي
ك
رحمه من الله
[موسيقى]
وتداول ايضا عدد من رواد مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي صور لمشهد مهيب للمعتمرين حول
الكعبه في شهر رمضان المبارك الصور
التقطها عبد الرحمن السهلي خلال وجود عدد
كبير من المعتمرين يؤدون الصلاه داخل صحن
الكعبه
انتشر مقطع فيديو على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي لاطفال يلعبون كره القدم في
مسجد بتركيا لكن هذا الفيديو تسبب بجدل
واسع بين مؤيد ومعارض البعض اعتبر هذا
تعديا على بيت الله ولا ينبغي السماح لمثل
هذه الممارسات داخل المساجد في المقابل
رحب اخرون مشيرين الى ان الامر مقبول ما
لم يؤثر سلبا على المصلين والشعائر كما
اعتبروا ذلك طريقه ايجابيه لترغيب الاطفال
في المساجد
[موسيقى]
تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع
فيديو لاحد مشجعين
عندما اقتحم الملعب من اجل تقديم عرض
الزواج ولكن عناصر الامن كان لديهم راي
اخر نشاهد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ظهرت العراقيه داليا نعيم بشكل اثاره جدلا
واسعا على مواقع التواصل اجتماعي وذلك بعد
ان كشفت عن وجهها الجديد وخضوعها لثلاث
واربعين عمليه تجميل لتشبه الدميه باربي
وقالت انها انفقت الاف من الاموال على هذه
العمليات الامر الذي جعلها محض انتقادات
واسعه وفقا لصحيفه الدليمي للبريطانيه
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء